consider the following piecewise
function and they say f of t is equal to
and they tell us what it's equal to
based on what t is so if t is less than
or equal to negative 10 we use this case
if t is between negative 10 and negative
2 we use this case and if t is greater
than or equal to negative 2 we use this
case and then they ask us what is the
value of f of negative 10. so t is going
to be equal to negative 10. so which
case do we use
so let's see if t is less than or equal
to negative 10 we use this top case
right over here and t is equal to
negative 10 that's the one that we're
trying to evaluate so we want to use
this case right over here
so f of negative 10 is going to be equal
to
negative 10 everywhere where we see a t
here we and we substitute it with a
negative 10 negative 10 squared minus 5
times actually i don't have a
denominator there i don't know why i
wrote it so high so it's going to be
negative 10
squared minus 5 times negative 10. so
let's see negative 10 squared that's
positive 100 and then negative or
subtracting 5 5 times negative 10 this
is going to be subtracting negative 50
or you're going to add 50 so this is
going to be equal to
150 f of negative 10 is 150 because we
used this case up here because t is
negative 10. let's do another one of
these examples
so here we have consider the following
piecewise function all right what is the
value of h of negative 3
see when h is negative 3 which case do
we use we use this case if if our x is
between negative infinity and 0 and
negative 3 is in between is between
negative infinity and 0. so we're going
to use this case right over here if it
was positive 3 we would use this case if
it was positive 30 we would use this
case so we're going to use the first
case again
and so we're going to so for h equal for
h of negative 3 we're going to take
negative 3 to the third power so let's
see h of negative 3 is going to be
negative 3 to the 3rd power which is
negative
and we're done that's h of negative 3.
because we are using this case you could
almost just ignore these second two
cases right over here let's do one more
example this one's a little bit
different
below is a graph of the step function g
of x so we could see g of x right over
here it start when x equals negative
nine it's at three and it jumps up and
then it jumps down match each expression
with its value so g of negative 3.0001
so negative 3.0001
so that's right over here and g of that
we see is equal to 3. so this is going
to be equal to 3 right over here
g of 3.99999
3.99999 almost almost 4. so let's draw
the dotted line right here it's going to
be almost 4.
well g of
3.99999 is going to be 7. we see that
right over there
so that is equal to 7. g of 4.0001
so g of 4 is still 7 but as soon as we
go above 4 we drop down over here so g
of 4.0001
is going to be negative 3.
i want to actually let's let's focus on
that a little bit more how did i know
that
well i know that g of 4 is 7 and not
negative 3 because we have this dot is
circled in up here and it's hollow down
here but as soon as we get any amount
larger than 4 then the function drops
down to this so
4.000 as many you know just slightly
above 4 the value of our function is
going to be negative 3.
now let's do g of 9.
so g of 9 so when x is 9 we go down here
you might be tempted to say it's
negative 3 but you see at this point
right over here we have an open circle
so that means that well it's not you
can't say that the function is negative
3 right over there and there's no other
place where we have a filled in circle
for x equals nine so the function g
actually isn't defined at x equals nine
so i'm going to put
undefined right over there